what if I told you there was a new
technology that when placed in the hands
of doctors and nurses improved outcomes
for children and adults patients of all
ages reduce pain and suffering reduced
time in the operating rooms reduced
anesthetic times had the ultimate dose
response curve that the more you did it
the better it benefited patients here's
a kicker it has no side effects and it's
available no matter where care is
delivered I can tell you as an ICU
doctor at Boston Children's Hospital
this would be a game-changer for me that
technology is lifelike rehearsal this
lifelike rehearsal is being delivered
through medical simulation I thought I
would start with a case just to really
describe the challenge ahead and why
this technology is not just going to
improve healthcare but why it's critical
to healthcare this is a child that's
born young girl day of life zero we call
it first day of life just born into the
world and just as she's being born we
noticed very quickly that she is
deteriorating her heart rate is going up
her blood pressure is going down she's
breathing very very fast and the reason
for this is displayed in this chest
x-ray I was called a baby Graham and
this is a full x-ray of a child's body
little infants body and as you look on
the top side of this that's where the
hearts and lungs are supposed to be and
as you look at the bottom and that's
where the abdomen is and that's where
the intestines are supposed to be and
you can see how there's sort of that
translucent area that's made its way up
into the right side of this child's
chest and that are the intestines in the
wrong place and as a result they're
pushing on the lungs and making it very
difficult for this poor baby to breathe
and the fix for this problem is to take
this child and media
to the operating room bring those
intestines back into the abdomen let the
lungs expand and allow this child to
breathe again
but before she can go to the operating
room she must get whisked away to the
ICU where I work and I work with
surgical teams and we gather around her
and we place this child on heart-lung
bypass we put her to sleep we make a
tiny little incision in the neck we
place catheters into the major vessels
of the neck and I can tell you that
these vessels are about the size of a
pen the tip of a pen and then we have
blood drawn from the body we bring it
through a machine it gets oxygenated and
it goes back into the body and we save
her life and get her safely to the
operating room here's the problem these
disorders what is known as congenital
diaphragmatic hernia this hole in the
diaphragm that has allowed these
intestines to sneak up these disorders
are rare even in the best hands in the
world there is still a challenge to get
the volume the natural volume of these
patients in order to get our expertise
curve at a hundred percent
they just don't present that often so
how do you make the rare common here's
the other problem in the healthcare
system that I trained for over 20 years
what currently exists the model of
training is called the apprenticeship
model it's been around for centuries
it's based on this idea that you see a
surgery maybe once maybe several times
you then go do that surgery and then
ultimately you teach that surgery to the
next generation
and implicit in this model I don't need
to tell you this is that we practice on
the very patients that we are delivering
care to that's a problem
and I think there's a better approach
medicine may very well be the last
high-stakes industry that does not
practice prior to game time and I want
to describe to you a better approach
through medical simulation well the
first thing we did is we went to other
high stakes industries that have been
using this type of methodology for
decades this is nuclear power nuclear
power runs scenarios on regular basis in
order to practice what they hope will
never occur and as we're all very
familiar the airline industry we all get
on planes now comforted by the idea that
pilots and crews have trained on
simulators much like these training on
scenarios that we hope will never occur
but we know if they did they would be
prepared for the worst
in fact the airline industry has gone as
far to create fuselages of simulation
environments because of the importance
of the team coming together this is an
evacuation drill simulator so that again
if that ever were to happen these rare
rare events they are ready to act on the
drop of a dime and I guess the most
compelling for me in some ways is the
sports industry arguably high stakes you
think about how a baseball team baseball
players practice I think it's a
beautiful example of progressive
training the first thing they do is they
go out to spring training they go to a
spring training camp
perhaps a simulator in baseball they're
not on the real field but they're on a
simulated field and they're playing in
the pregame season then they make their
way to the field during the season games
and what's the first thing they do
before they start the game they go into
the batting cage and they do batting
practice for hours having different
types of pitches being thrown at them
hitting ball after ball as they limber
their muscles getting ready for the game
itself and here's the most phenomenal
part of this and for all of you who
watch any sport event you will see this
phenomena happen
the batter gets into the batter's box
the pitcher gets ready to pitch right
before the pitch is thrown what does
that batter do the batter steps out of
the box and takes it practically he
wouldn't do it any other way I want to
talk to you about how we're building
practice swings like this in medicine we
have building batting cages for the
patients that we care about at Boston
Children's I want to use this case that
we recently built the case of a four
year old who had a progressively
enlarging head and as a result had loss
of developmental milestones neurologic
milestones and the reason for this
problem is here it's called
hydrocephalus so a quick quick study in
neurosurgery so there's the brain and
you can see the cranium surrounding the
brain and what surrounds the brain
actually between the brain and the
cranium is something called
cerebrospinal fluid or fluid which acts
as a shock absorber and in your heads
right now there is cerebral spinal fluid
just bathing your brains and making its
way around it it's produced in one area
and flows through and then it's
reexpansion this beautiful flow pattern
occurs for all of us but unfortunately
in some children there's a blockage of
this flow pattern much like a traffic
jam and as a result the fluid
accumulates and the brain is pushed
aside and has difficulty growing and as
a result the child loses neurologic
milestones so this is a devastating
disease and children so the cure for
this is surgery and the traditional
surgery is to take a bit of the cranium
off a bit of the skull drain this fluid
out stick a drain in place and then
eventually bring this drain internal to
the body big operation but some great
news is that advances in neurosurgeon
neurosurgical cares have allowed us to
develop minimally invasive approaches to
this surgery so through a small pinhole
a camera can be inserted led into the
deep straight brain structure and cause
a little hole in a membrane that allows
all that
fluid to drain much like it would be in
a sink and all of a sudden now the brain
is no longer under pressure can
re-expand and we cure the child through
a single hole incision but here's the
problem hydrocephalus is relatively rare
and there are no good training methods
to get really good at getting this scope
to the right place but surgeons have
been quite creative about this even our
own and they've come up with training
models here's the current training model
I kid you not this is a red pepper not
made in Hollywood it's a real put red
pepper and what surgeons do is they
stick a scope into the pepper and they
do what it's called a seed ectomy they
use this scope to remove seeds using a
little tweezer and that is a way to get
under their belts the rudimentary
components of doing this surgery and
then they head right into the
apprenticeship model seeing many of them
as they present themselves then doing it
and then teaching it waiting for these
patients to arrive we can do a lot
better we are manufacturing
reproductions of children in order for
surgeons and surgical teams to rehearse
in the most relevant possible ways and
let me show you this so here's my team
in what's called a sim engineering
division of the simulator program this
is an amazing team of individuals they
are mechanical engineers you're seeing
here illustrators they take primary data
from CT scans and MRIs translate it into
digital information and it made it put
it together into the components of the
child itself surface scan elements of
the child that have been casted as
needed depending on the surgery itself
and then take this digital data and be
able to output it on state-of-the-art
three-dimensional printing devices that
allow us to print the components exactly
to the micron detail of what the child's
Anatomy will look
and you can see here the skull of this
child being printed in the hours before
we perform this surgery but we could not
do this work without our dear friends on
the west coast in Hollywood California
and these are individuals that are
incredibly talented at being able to
recreate reality and it was not a long
leap for us the more we got into this
field the more it became clear to us
that we are doing cinematography we're
doing filmmaking it's just that the
actors are not actors they're real
doctors and nurses and so these are some
photos of our dear friends at fractures
effects in Hollywood California and Emmy
award-winning special effects firm and
this is Justin Rowley and his group this
is not one of our patients but kind of
the exquisite work that these
individuals do and we have now
collaborated and fused our experience
bringing their group to Boston
Children's Hospital sending our group
out to Hollywood California and
exchanging around this to be able to
develop these type of simulators what
I'm about to show you is a reproduction
of this child and you'll notice here
that every hair on the child's head is
reproduced and in fact this is also that
reproduced child and I apologize for any
queasy stomachs but that is a
reproduction and simulation of the child
are about to operate on and here is that
membrane we had talked about the inside
of this child's brain and what you're
going to be seeing here is on one side
the actual patient and on the other side
the simulator as I mentioned a scope a
little camera needs to make its way down
you're seeing that here and it needs to
make a small hole in this membrane allow
this fluid to seep out and I won't do a
quiz show to see who thinks which side
is which but on the right is the
simulated
and so surgeons can now produce training
opportunities do these surgeries as many
times as they want until their heart's
content until they feel comfortable and
then and only then bring the child into
the operating room but we don't stop
here we know that a key step to this is
not just the skill itself but combining
that skill with a team who's going to
deliver that care and so now we turn to
formula 1 and here is an example of a
technician putting a tire and doing that
time and time again on this car but that
is very quickly going to be incorporated
within team training experiences now as
a full team orchestrating the exchange
of tires and getting this car back on
the Speedway and so we've done that step
in healthcare so now what you're going
to about to see is this is now a
simulated operation we've taken a
simulator I've just described to you we
brought it into the operating room at
Boston Children's Hospital and these
individuals these native teams operative
teams are doing the surgery before the
surgery operate twice cut once let me
show that to you with the head over here
Emily oh yeah and then lower the whole
table down a little bit people coming
all right Gaming lucky stuff like we
have a scissor back wages adequate ITV
kneidlach
eight and a half already another bigger
tip it's really amazing and the second
step to this which is critical as we
take these teams out immediately and we
debrief them we use the same
technologies that are used in lean and
Six Sigma in the military and we bring
them out and we talk about what went
right but more importantly we talk about
what didn't go well and how are we going
to fix it and then we bring them right
back in and we do it again deliberative
batting practice in the moments when it
matters most so let's go back to this
case now same child but now let me
describe how we care for this child at
Boston Children's Hospital this child
was born it's three o'clock in the
morning at two o'clock in the morning we
assembled the team and took the
reproduced anatomy that we would gain
out of scans and images and brought that
team to the virtual bedside to a
simulated bedside the same team that's
going to operate on this child in hours
ahead and we have them do the procedure
to show you a moment of this this is not
a real incision and the baby has not yet
been born
imagine this so now the conversations
that I have with families in the
intensive care unit Boston Children's
Hospital are totally different
imagine this conversation not only do we
take care of this disorder frequently in
our ICU and not only have we done
surgeries like the surgery we're going
to do on your child but we have done
your child's surgery and we did it two
hours ago and we did it 10 times and now
we're prepared to take them back to the
operating room so a new technology in
healthcare lifelike rehearsal
dissing prior to game time
thank you
[Applause]